let's go on guys welcome to a quick
Python tutorial video regarding how to
reverse the order of a Python list
quickly and simply so the first thing
we're going to need is a list so let's
just say x equals and let's make this a
pretty simple list and it'll be just 1 2
3 4 5 6 and 9 and now what we want to do
is reverse it so we can do y equals
reversed X but that's not all we have to
do just yet because if I show you what
happens here like let's print Y out and
we run this and you'll see that it's
perfect it's producing iterable so what
we need to do now is instead of saying
that we're done at that point we can
instead do something like this Z equals
an empty array and then for each it in Y
we can print each it if we want and
we'll just do that for now and we'll
just print it out and so you can see
actually that it did reverse it 19 7 6 4
3 2 1 boy the next thing we can do is we
can say Z dot append each it and we'll
just comment that out and now at the end
of this let's print X Z run that and now
you can see that we have indeed reverse
the order and now we have an actual list
that we can now work with so hopefully
you guys found that interesting
hopefully you learned something new as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support and subscriptions and
selection